ramon Arnel posed the question a few
times during the film why mean why was I
chosen for this what do you think that
his story and are now himself represents
to the Filipino community because you
see why he was chosen phenomenal voice
amazing presence on stage what do you
think he represents um the good part I
think of the Filipino community the
positive energy I think of the community
you know the Filipino community the
filipina and filipino american community
in this country we claim everyone who's
like up tents Filipino you know we claim
Bruno Mars for example we claim Apple
that he is a Filipino but to have
someone like her now who's a hundred
percent Philip you know coming from the
Philippines it's over the top and I
think they see themselves you know it's
like he's also and he says this he's
like I'm the most famous filipina
immigrant in this country so he's a very
accessible character and yet he's
reached a level that makes every
Filipino proud I think and he he's still
humble you know his character i think
really i think it was attracts the
community cuz he still takes time out
for every fan that comes up to him he
will I mean good and bad right because
then he has all these plans to say go to
a grocery store but he every fan that
comes out to him he will accommodate so
miracle his plans but i think it's just
his humility you know that attracts the
community and they rally around that
they rally around him
you